bill is with us in New York I bill how
are you hi Dave how you doing better
than I deserve what's up I have a little
bit of a sticky situation before we got
married my wife co-signed with her her
brother-in-law her sister's husband on a
house and they actually needed a third
cosigner so my wife had her friend also
co-signed so it's three owners they own
it together
yes it's three co-owners Oh co-owners as
well as co-signers great who lives in
the house um the brother-in-law lives in
the house and when I first met my wife
she told me that her and her
brother-in-law had a deal where she was
paying 5050 for repairs and she was
paying 50% of the utilities why and I
said that sounds like a really great
deal for your brother-in-law why is she
paying half the utilities in their
personal house she doesn't live it I
have no idea so when I told her that
that's bogus you know and I'm not paying
that as I'm getting married and I want
to start planning for my family so when
we got married she uh she moved and she
left her job so she's not been working
so we just found out that 12 months ago
our her brother-in-law stopped paying
the mortgage and we got a foreclosure
notice and we asked him what's going on
he said he's trying to get the mortgage
lowered so he's doing some type of
strategic default he saw some legal
advice about this yeah I bet he did this
guy has to get something for nothing all
the time doesn't he yeah so we asked him
how can you do this without telling the
other two people whose credit is gonna
be affected already it's offeri already
is affected yeah right already I guess
there's no written agreement on this bad
partnership idea is there no none at all
what city or what state is this house in
New York it's in Queens New York Lord so
what I wanted to know is since my wife
isn't working
we saw some legal advice and our lawyer
told us we need to move to short sale
yeah well we can't even list the house
without his signature yeah you can't
sell another signature is around right
and we
want to know if if the bank thinks my
wife isn't working if the bank can come
after after me no like you come after
here you didn't sign anything but
anything you and your wife owned
together do you own a home together no
we went ok do you have any bank accounts
that have her names on them we did but
we changed all that when we found out
about this issue and we put all our
savings in lassie under my name so she
does not own anything except for that
house now but I mean she doesn't own
anything they would come after is my
point
no the cars names are in whose names of
cars in mine okay right but very very
difficult for them to get anything from
her because she doesn't have anything so
that puts you in a position to negotiate
after the foreclosure her credit is
going to get destroyed he's going to get
foreclosed on there's not probably a lot
you can do to stop it
and then they will chase all three of
the makers for the deficit possibly do
we know what kind of loan this is FHA VA
or conventional um I'm not sure I think
it's a conventional okay then if it is
then they can chase you for the deficit
her for the deficit which means that if
they sell the house for less than is
owed on it they in foreclosure they will
come after the borrowers for that
difference or they can they can't get
anything from your wife and so you'd be
in a position to settle for at least her
portion of the deficit so her credit is
going to have an atom bomb dropped on it
by this really dumb idea that she
engaged in the only other thing you can
do and it's not worth it and I wouldn't
do it but technically you could file a
motion with an attorney to force this
partnership to be liquidated and forced
the sale of the house have the
court-ordered sale of the house because
the brother-in-law is not going to do
anything he's going to sit there and try
to get the thing for free those all the
rest of his life
because that's how this guy works he's a
parasite right and so he's not going to
do anything unless you make him with a
judge but it didn't worth it if your
wife had you know it had a half million
dollars and we thought they were coming
after a half million dollars of hers
would be worth filing a fifteen thousand
dollar lawsuit to force to sell the
house and keep telling that your
liability do you see what I'm saying
but she's virtually what we call
judgment proof and so I just wouldn't
fool with it but that means we can't put
anything in the future under her name
not until this is cleared up and it'll
be a few years before it clears well
eventually the house will get foreclosed
on and then eventually they will chase
you and call you and you can settle with
them for her portion okay and so what is
the house worth do you think well I know
how much the we just got an appraiser
we're waiting on the appraiser roughly
what is it worth I would say probably
350 and what is owed on it arm about 400
okay
so let's pretend it went through
foreclosure and sold for 300 and they
came after you guys for a hundred and
you said well this guy's the guy and she
doesn't have any money we'll settle with
you for ten thousand dollars for her
portion and you settle for her portion
and then they go away and they can chase
the other two borrower's then and that's
kind of how it will go down something
like that but that's probably like three
four years from now okay
so there's nothing to worry about in the
meantime if we did a short sale if you
can talk him into doing a short sale it
keeps everybody from having a liability
but you got to talk parasite boy into
selling his house he's got free and good
luck with that forgives us if the bank
forgives us with the IRS tax that
canceled that mmm I don't know you'd
have to check your tax guy on that
because you're not living in the house
if it's personal residence they don't
but this isn't personal residence so
that's what we got to figure out
you